Rio de Janeiro the Brazilian cities
known for its stunning beaches cheerful
people and heavy traffic it's also
considered one of the most dangerous
cities in the world driving a cab can be
pretty risky
that's what gave Rodrigo terios the idea
for an app security in a taxi it's
something that hit my family a few years
ago fortunately I lost member of my
family due to a robbery he was a taxi
driver and he was killed and that really
start up on me an idea that we need to
solve this problem it's a simple idea
the app uses your smartphone's camera to
monitor what's going on inside the cab
a sign advises passengers they're being
watched positioned correctly the camera
can fit everyone into the picture canoes
and SEGA tax i use the sect taxi half
because i think it's important to invest
in security not only for me but also for
my passengers got a mage most passengers
don't have an issue with the camera
after all they're used to being watched
when we told the digital guide is as in
all public places libraries restaurants
gas stations and others it's common to
have internal security cameras told the
stain when you told a man to commit it
to save on storage space the images are
immediately transferred to a server that
preserves potential evidence
particularly if the driver's phone is
stolen the service costs 12 years a
month to save on data volume the service
transfers images rather than video
footage there's also a backup system in
case of a poor connection data
protection rules mean the images can be
kept for a maximum of 48 hours that
security surveillance is a big problem
for us and we are taking all the
measures necessary to assure the images
that are being uploaded shell servers
are going to a secure server the
detection drive did do not have direct
access to the image the stills are later
compiled into a video enabling
investigators to piece together the
sequence of a crime the footage is only
released if requested by the police or
an insurance company plans are also in
the works to incorporate a GPS tracker
into the app they're going should be
able to take my nine years old daughter
and put her in a cab and be able to
follow her through her way to her dance
lessons so far the apps only available
in Portuguese but developers hope to
release an english-language version for
the international market to
shift says safe trip